well they vomit actually Michael Gove
warned recently that winter is coming he
was talking about brexit but referring
of course to the famous line from Game
of Thrones and in fact Game of Thrones
itself is coming out to some parts of
the UK at least as it goes on tour to
coincide with the show's final season
which begins later this month I promise
to fight for the living
[Music]
I intend to keep that promise
[Music]
well it means superconn she hosts the
throne cast on Sky Atlantic welcome to
Indy we're all very excited aren't we
absolutely so you're a fan I take it Oh
favorite character can I draw you on
that I've been at work Tyrion or Darius
or a lot of men a woman yeah well I see
I'm a fan of Cersei Circe's
manipulations and double-crossing
fantastic acting she's extraordinary
she's extraordinary
so yes it's back 15th of April yeah and
now you do the kind of reaction and
discussion yes yeah do you BAM bricks it
or does bricks it basic walls come into
the discussion of because the show is so
extraordinary we don't need to mention
brexit but what the more one talks about
Game of Thrones the more the natural you
know sort of parallels do merge I mean
you could be up against the Tory
leadership contest that at the same time
you know I remember when and yeah how's
the original house of cards coincided
with the fall of Thatcher reality yes
exactly mirrors it perfectly well we'll
say very much in our world and let's I
mean sometimes it feels like Game of
Thrones is more procedural compared to
the fantasy elements of governance at
the moment would the world be better if
we if I mean you know we had a lot about
principle dinosaurs but would it be
better if we had dragons dragons would
certainly end the deadlock I mean if you
deploys deployed a dragon over
Westminster I think things would motor
pretty quickly and yeah I mean there's
this zombie dragon now isn't there one
of the three got killed yes spoilers yes
so yes but the night the night's king
sort of killed one of the one of
Daenerys dragons and now yes working for
the dark side and laid waste to the
great wall yeah destroyed it in one one
I see breath so the battle between the
living and the dead now it's gonna
occupy it at the last season do you know
what's gonna happen I didn't know
anything when we started out doing the
companion show we were given tapes to
watch all week in advance I just had to
type in a password and I can see it all
and then gradually as the shows become
more of a global phenomenon we're not
allowed to see it I think two years ago
I was allowed to see it the
before in an edit suite with three
cameras trained on me to make sure it
wasn't you know jeepers casing a copy
and now I watch it 2:00 a.m. as everyone
asked us and there's an American time
you have to watch that and then you have
to go straight into training so we just
get the headlines of the episode so we
can we can sort of garner from that what
may or may not be happening and I mean
it has become a huge huge why do you
think because part of its very easily
relatable so it's a sort of soap opera
on one hand we were all used to sort of
patiska masa nations and the quest for
power and ambition and then but it's
displaced into a fantasy zone where
there as you say there are dragons and
there are White Walkers zombies and so
we can process actually quite difficult
things about human nature through the
prism of do you think it's it's sort of
softened a bit in as much as in the
early pop series it was brilliant
because major characters would get
killed or written or you just love that
bit you love that well no because it was
kind of like real life in a sense that
happens but now we've got that cast of I
suppose about you know eight characters
yeah and they and they don't really want
to see the back of any of them I mean
take Jon Snow he was killed but they had
to bring him back you know he has it got
more schmaltz eg for me actually I think
it's obviously the the first few seasons
were very true to the books and they've
subsequently departed because poor
george RR martin can't write but it's
quick enough now i think you'd mention
house of cards for me it's become much
more about the political infighting and
i love that i mean in the end isn't it
it's gonna be like everything else is
that Daenerys and Jon Snow gonna cop off
together and live happy ever off I think
that's that's not that I mean I don't
know I I have been given no inside
information but I I don't think that's
how it's going to pan out well you think
you'd be a sad ending I think well I
I've heard somebody said it makes them
somebody said that there are scenes that
make the red wedding look like a sort of
a picnic so I think there's going to be
a lot of the characters that we know
that be the nightwalkers annihilating
everybody but that would be the ugly
ones
now that's a very near listing end game
so you're thinking that the zombies will
end up for
on the throne and the throne will turn
to ice underneath his tissue really
would have arrived uh he would you like
to see on the throne here's your here's
your prettiest gotta be the mother of
dragons hasn't it yeah I think that's
gonna be too obvious I'm gonna go for
son sir that's my pick but again I don't
know